[Music]
all right guys
there's a bunch of different ways to
cheat in games some
more subtle than others but it's a whole
different issue when you're cheating
and there's something on the line so
today we wanted to take a look at
esports's dirtiest cheaters
not just the random streamer but the
highest profile of cheating scandals in
esports
here are the top 10 dirtiest cheaters in
esports
kicking off our list may be the single
stupidest cheating scandal in esports
history
before he signed with optic india
forsaken was a player mostly known for
demolishing whatever pug he played in
but the only thing more confusing than
his signing was his gameplay
at extremes land zowie asia 2018
forsaken was hitting tracking head shots
nailing flicks and hitting unthinkable
spray transfers
he was looking like the next simple the
entry into the b bomb site doesn't go
well
she looks like a real thought
but he manages to make it work but
tournament admins immediately took
notice of his suspicious gameplay
turns out he was cheating and had all
his cheats on a file on his computer
that he hilariously called
word.exe when he got figured out he even
fought with tournament admins while
desperately trying to delete it before
they saw
forsaken thought that he could fool
everyone but in the end
all he did was turn himself into a meme
i did who put word exe on
now you might not think that you can
cheat in virtual cycling but our number
nine entry proves that
anything is possible uh yes e-cycling an
esport almost no one is aware of but
somehow had a cheating scandal in its
first year of operation
and as of the 18th of september 2019 i
am disqualified
disgraced and banned from the sport of
cycling
cameron jeffers a youtuber and cyclist
really wanted to compete in the british
cycling esports championship grand
finals
but he wanted to get a bike that would
give him an edge over the competition
so he set up some bots and had them
grind their way to getting him the zwift
concept z1
a pretty sweet looking tron bike and
then he won the tournament
and winner of the gold medal your
national champion
is going to be cameron jeffers but there
was one small problem
he didn't actually earn the bike some
sort of software on
on your computer and you can essentially
just put in like a power value for
example like 400 watts click enter
and your avatar within the game will
just sit at 400 watts about like you
having to pedal
which british cycling really didn't like
they stripped him of his gold medal
find him 250 pounds and called his
actions
robo-doping yeah
coming in at number eight is a cheating
scandal that pubg might never recover
from
and it is a day that will go down in
which a bunch of players get banned for
cheating that's basically what's
happened
in 2018 pubg saw a huge explosion in
popularity which of course
led to an esports scene things were
going pretty well that is
until several pros were caught in a
massive cheating scandal
back then there was a cheat going around
called the radar hack
it's complicated but it basically let
you see where every other player on the
map was without revealing yourself
that's insanely powerful and using that
in tournament would give any cheating
pros a huge
advantage the other kid yo just get the
car and go all the way to that hut
in the front you're going to gatekeep
them they're outside of pochinki
that's it y'all won good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
laser
we discovered that 10 players have
received in-game bans due to the usage
of unauthorized programs
the type of which has been severely
damaging to the integrity of the game of
pubg
while many of the players who were
caught using the raider hack weren't
exactly at their prime
it was still a huge black mark on the
scene even now
it's hard to look back at geisley thc
winning the broadcaster royale
it just doesn't feel right
taking the number 7 spot on our list is
a cheetah that just cracked
under the pressure apx void is someone
who was generally well
liked by the hearthstone community i
have to blow a kiss to my stream because
i kept telling them i wouldn't
so awkward though because there's so
many people and it's like
it's fine this is the best time to blow
a kiss
you said you'd
i blew you a kiss chat i was cringy but
that's okay we got one
and i promised which makes what comes
next
that much worse while playing in the
last round of the swiss stage during the
hct winter playoffs
the canadian cracked under the pressure
void typed up a message to a friend that
was sitting right next to him
asking how he should play a specific
matchup in the game unfortunately for
void the admins decided that was
cheating and he was immediately
disqualified
shortly after that his sponsor dropped
him too
these days things are looking up though
void's slowly been climbing his way back
up in the circuit
and his situation has become a lesson on
how not to deal with the pressure of
competition
beautifully played from both sides apex
played his threats
he checked the answers and he he
he made a really good balance of pushing
pushing damage to face
while still managing a bloody face cn
sport
now cheating and mobas can be pretty
hard but thunder predator somehow
managed to do it
and in the process earn the sixth spot
on our list
well they are going to find the faint
will we see a roar not quite yet meepo
throws in and that this should be at
least to kill the bank he does get the
brain step off which goes one of the
weirder ways that you can cheat in dota
2
is to use a mouse macro which
essentially lets you use spells and
abilities at speeds that no normal human
could hit
and that's exactly what a tune from
thunder predator did at the ti-8 south
american qualifier
and this dude wasn't even trying to hide
it look at him poof all of his meepo's
at the exact same time
oh well they're gonna find just one it's
gonna be a big one it's gonna be the
bane with no buyback they're just going
in a tune does kill the necro book three
and scofield just take a lot damn
they're just sitting here killing
buildings admins immediately picked up
on this after an uproar from the
community and thunder predator were
disqualified from the qualifiers
taking the number five spot on our list
is the tsm versus azubu frost scandal
from the league of legends season 2
world championship so it's the
quarterfinals tsm versus azubu frost in
a high stakes best of three
but for some reason the players kept
looking away from their monitors
alright and as we jump into game we have
woong on the screen we can see him going
down to the bottom of the map by himself
it quickly became clear that due to the
production setup both teams could
actually see the audience's screen which
was showing the stream
that meant they knew exactly where the
other team was on the map
which if you don't know league is kind
of broken for example people were
confused by how zubro frost was able to
react
so well to tsm's movement anybody to
come through and invade the blue they
also have again
flux and maokai in that mid but they are
freak they went around that top brush
turns out they were watching the stream
just like the fans at home
and after the match reginald immediately
accused the korean team of cheating
we looked straight to zoom frost and
chaos notices
their players looking at our map looking
at the mini map
and they start like talking and then um
there's also proof in the replay that
there's been pings at dark areas where
we're standing
where they have no vision of so i mean
that's kind of shady in my opinion
after further investigation from riot
games azubu frost refined 30
thousand dollars bringing this scandal
to a close
now it's one thing to cheat in an
esports tournament with money on the
line but it's a whole other issue to
cheat in a charity event
and when you stoop that low you get the
number four spot on this list
nick 830 and david morgan nikkei 30 made
his name off of being a family-friendly
fortnite content creator on youtube
but it was hard to see him that way
after he broke the rules of a charity
event run by twitch
now the rules of the tournament stated
that you had to land in a specific part
of the map
but nikkei 30 landed in other parts so
that he could get better loot but nick
830
with this partner right on top of chap
he's at one hp
and he's not gonna be able to win it
they continue his
rise to the top no no no i got them both
little by little we're seeing i'm gonna
perform here
in sixth or seventh place coming in the
worst part is that he didn't even get
punished the will stated that for your
first offense you only got a warning
nikki 30 knew this which is why he
cheated in the first place
so i think what we want to do because
remember
we don't mean he plays all right then we
just go back as does nate hill
it's not about him so did he really
cheat
or was he just aggressively bending the
rules i guess you could say
in some cases cheating is in the eye of
the beholder
taking the third spot on our list is a
cheater who got a quick smackdown from
epic games
faze jarvis yeah they've given me
aimbots
actually jarvis was just like any other
fortnite content creator on youtube
making
wacky videos in fortnight for a young
audience that was until he decided to
make a video
experimenting with an aimbot so you guys
can see on my screen
i've definitely got the hacks you can
see where people are going for some
reason it doesn't show on streamlabs obs
but let's just run it not even a subtle
one or
anything just a blatant aimbot doming
people from across the map
oh
i'm sorry what i'm sorry what
did you just stop the game now of course
epic games took notice of this he
literally put it on youtube for everyone
to see and they
permanently banned jarvis from fortnite
like i just wish i could have known how
badly i was messing up because i would
never
have ever thought of even making those
kind of videos if i knew that this could
have actually happened
i know now how big of a safe this was
and like
i it's just there's nothing i can
coming in at the runner-up spot on our
list is a player whose ban and
subsequent reformation
leaves us suspicious to this day okay we
are
kind of cheating here but you know we
had to cover this on this list
so shaika was an unreal french prodigy
that was making his way through the
ranks in rainbow six siege
but during a match against penta siege
superstar pengu felt like shaco's shots
were suspicious
and called for further action a lot of
rumors going on that there was some
suspicious
stuff going on and no one could really
point to what it was
this story was that he had more
information than you humanly possibly
could so that would refer to what we
call wall hacks or some sort of way to
gain information that you shouldn't
otherwise have as
a normal human being and the first boat
of contact a great shot shika what an
unbelievable kill on junus there
we beat them in a very very very close
game and
we protested because we had suspicion
that something was wrong
esl investigated whether or not shaika
was legit and they found that the four
key on his keyboard was being pressed at
an
inhuman rate esl banned the frenchman
for two years without any appeal though
they did lift it a little early
and once he was free shiko clapped pengu
at dreamhack montreal
shaikh was in a great spot to find
another kill here if things quiet down
oh going off he finds pengu what
what and baby and as well a triple for
chico
this is an unreal performance he's
continuing it over the bank
since then there's been no issue and he
still maintains his godly form
but at the end of the day shaiku did get
punished for cheating
whether or not he actually did it though
is a question that remains to this day
taking the top spot on our list is the
cheater that put the entire
counter-strike scene
in crisis mode if it turns out
this is this is all accurate then the
band is is warranted and the person did
cheat
this is a case of a top-level pro who
has skill having
cheated and the implications
unfortunately
are quite huge back in 2014 cali was
making a name for himself as a capable
player in the french scene
even making the top four of a major and
winning eswc 2013.
kelly against pasha the two players
who've stepped up phenomenally
for their side i can't believe what i'm
witnessing right here
wow get out of here
you believe it to secure the final kill
in that round but one day out of nowhere
cali got a vac ban effectively removing
him from the pro scene forever
no one knew if he used cheats on lan or
even in an online match
and it threw the entire cs go world into
disarray
we need to know all these things because
implications are more than just this
player and his account is now
backplanned okay is that it so you've
detected something in his account
it's banned is that the end of the story
that can't be the end of the story in
this particular case
and that meant anyone could be cheating
accusations started
flying and while the cs community
eventually settled down
a lot of people were still suspicious
about whether some pros had cheated
and were just never caught i know that a
couple of my teammates are convinced
that they think they cheat all right
guys
that's our list did we miss any that you
feel should have been on it maybe it was
that guy you were playing on dust2 last
night who just kept running down
mid every single time with the deagle
and doming you every single goddamn
round
leave your comments down below and we'll
talk about it
are you threatening me master jedi my my
[ __ ] default like
english accent is australian okay are
you threatening me master jedi
the senate will decide your thing i am
the senate